what is up everybody at Santa Mack here
for anime uproar and today we will be
talking about the crazy plot twist that
just happened in the black clover story
a plot twist that I honestly did not see
coming
this absolutely massive development has
left me in shock and I am honestly not
sure exactly what to make of it but
during the course of this video I will
do my best to flesh out exactly what
happened in Chapter 214 and I will
examine what type of impact the events
of this chapter are going to have on the
black lower story going forward if you
enjoyed the black clover content on this
channel you want to see more please
leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to anime uproar don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell you can follow me on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar for all the
latest black clover news and updates and
of course i will be talking about the
latest developments in the black clover
stories so manga spoilers will be coming
proceed with caution you have been
warned the chapter starts off with the
souls of the elves floating up to the
sky and in the previous chapter the
reincarnated laked had made it clear
that he does not intend to stay in his
artificial body and that instead he
intends to join his wife in the
afterlife so in this chapter rod
espírito steps up and uses the evolved
form of his sole corpse magic to revive
Patri soul inside the artificial body
that Licht had been using you will
recall that rod is first developed the
ability to actually bring the souls of
the Dead back inside their bodies after
Patri sacrificed him and his comrades
Sally and Val toast back in chapter 166
back then he was able to bring himself
Sally and Val toast back from the dead
and in this chapter he uses his magic to
revive Patri soul inside the artificial
body of late now this explains that he
was able to do this because the
artificial body was initially created
based on Patras body so Patri soul was
highly compatible with the body itself
but odd as then goes on a bit of a
confused rant where he tells Patri that
he can't just leave into a peaceful
afterlife after everything he has done
and all the humans that he has trampled
on and oddest wants him to live forever
so that he has to live with the
consequences of all of his actions
radha's then makes some threats that he
will be the one to one day kill Patri
and exact his revenge and that Patri
doesn't deserve an easy death anyway but
Patri appears to see his revival as a
blessed
an opportunity to actually atone for all
the terrible things that he has done
Patri then has a brief heartfelt moment
with his dearest friend William who he
can now actually touch and speak to as
someone separate from himself but pachi
says that even though they can't expect
forgiveness they must go on and
apologize to all the people that they
have wronged starting with the wizard
King Julius Noah chrono has all the
magic Knights of the clover kingdom are
working to cope with the destruction
from the massive battle against the
elves oz to admit that he is actually in
terrible pain and all points out that he
pushed himself too far again the first
wizard King Lumiere thanks astha for
finally destroying the devil's binding
curse that has existed for over 500
years
although hasta knows that he was only
able to do it with the help of another
devil who dwells within his grimoire as
Noel mimosa and hasta come to terms with
the fact that the actual first wizard
king is there talking to them and that
nero was actually a human girl all along
and as Noel of course gets jealous of
nero because she is now a cute girl that
is also close to hasta Lumiere explains
that he has run out of Daman are
required to maintain his connection to
the body that he is currently using
Lumiere thanks Sacre AKA nero for
helping him protect the future from the
500 year old threat and he tells her
that he looks forward to her living on
in the present and continuing to protect
the clover kingdom along with the
current magic Knights
Lumiere also says that he is happy to
have been able to meet his own
descendants by what she means Noel and
mimosa who are members of the royal
family and therefore direct descendants
of the first wizard king's royal
bloodline
in a recent volume of the manga we got
Lumiere's character profile and there it
is revealed that his last name is silver
million this suggests that the silva and
vermilion noble families were once part
of the same family silver million but
they split at some point in the past
this would explain why both memo signed
Noel are direct descendants of Lumiere
despite having different last names
sacré is of course heartbroken that the
first wizard king has to leave because
she loved being able to serve alongside
him for all of this time and Lumiere
thanks her for everything before his
current body disintegrates elsewhere
Yami and William are trying to locate
the wizard Kings body but for some
reason his body is missing
suddenly they turn around and see
something in the forest behind them and
a voice calls out to them saying I'm
sorry for disappointing you all by not
being able to help in the kingdom's
moment of crisis
I thought the effect of my magic would
kick in a bit faster I think it was
about 13 years worth that's how much
time I had saved up but it was a gamble
as to whether or not it would be able to
activate properly at that point we see
the star that has always been on the
wizard King Julius as forehead
disintegrate and then we see Julius
himself alive and wearing his normal
usual clothes but he looks much much
younger we really have to wait for the
coming chapters to figure out exactly
what happened here and how Julius has
time magic was able to save him but this
is my guest so far
Julius managed to save up 13 years worth
of time during the course of his life he
was able to do this because his time
magic enables him to steal and store the
time of others and then use this time
later for his spells my guess is that
when Julius was killed by Patri he ran
out of time he was dead so his time was
up but with the help of a mysterious
spell that is clearly related to the
star symbol that was tattooed on his
forehead he was able to revive himself
and he was then able to go from zero
time to 13 years because of the time
that he had saved up so instead of
having zero time Julius is now 13 years
old because he added those saved up
years on to himself when he revived at
13 he is definitely going to be very
young but at least he will be capable of
thinking and interacting with others on
a normal level if he had been revived
with zero time he would have just been a
baby so he would have been useless as
the wizard King again though this is
just me speculating it seems to me that
he combines some sort of unknown revival
spell with the 13 years that he had
saved up in order to make himself come
back to life at the age of 13
Julius grimoire has also been revived
along with him although his grimoire is
now just a single page so this likely
means that Julius will need to relearn
all of the magical spells that he once
knew and if that is the case then you
can expect him to be going on adventures
with austa and the crew and training
with them until he reloads all of his
old Pete Time magic spells that he was
able to do in the past and also if
Julius really did lose most of his
spells and abilities it is possible that
the kingdom will still need to find a
replacement for him a 13 year old kid
who has to relearn all of his powers
would not be the most effective wizard
king so someone else may have to step in
and become the next wizard king until
Julius reaches his former levels of
power but we will have to wait and see I
will be keeping a close eye on the
coming chapters and I'll be looking for
how exactly Julius managed to revive
himself and how this will affect the
story moving forward but now let's talk
about what I actually think about the
events of this chapter I know that a lot
of people are upset that Julius was
revived after everything that just
happened in this arc and I definitely
understand where they are coming from
the sacrifice that Julius made in his
fight against Patri was so powerful and
so meaningful and it shaped the story
going forward the fact that he didn't
actually die or rather than he died but
then he was brought back to life really
cheapens the sacrifice that he made it
changes the story completely yes it's
true that we've always known that Julius
his time Magic was extremely opie and if
even radha's can now bring people back
from the dead then is it that much of a
stretch to think that Julius could pull
this off no I would say that within the
world of black clover this is not a
stretch it is surprising it is
unexpected but it is definitely not
something that is out of the realm of
possibility for this magical world I
definitely find Julius as magic to be
very interesting I loved him as a
character and a part of me is very
excited to learn more about him and
about his time magic at the same time a
part of me is disappointed that his
meaningful sacrifice has now been
negated I'm also not a huge fan of this
whole Patri revival either I know that
he has been changing as a character but
he still did horrible things and he did
them by acting on false information
without actually checking to see what
really happened during the elf massacre
does Patras redemption and atonement
really need to be a major component of
the black clover story going forward do
we even need poetry to be an important
character in the future I would have to
say no there are plenty of interesting
characters in black clover and many of
them are a lot more likeable than Patri
at least in my opinion but with that
said I don't want to jump to conclusions
and say that the story has been ruined
because of what happened with poetry and
Julia
I will give Tabata the benefit of the
doubt and see where he takes the story
from here if he can explain everything
in a satisfying way and if he can use
the young Julius and pachi in ways that
work for the story then I will be able
to roll with the latest twists without a
problem but if these latest developments
end up taking away from the story or not
fitting in with the rest of the story
then I may have to give all of this some
more serious thought but suffice it to
say I have no plans of dropping black
clover any time soon I've been loving
the story thus far and I think Yuki
Tabata deserves the benefit of the doubt
on this one with that said please let me
know what you guys think are you angry
that pachi and Julius were revived or
are you happy and why and how do you
think that these major twists are going
to affect the story going forward please
let me know down in the comments I'm
really interested in hearing everyone's
opinion on these massive reveals if you
enjoyed the black clover content on this
channel you can leave a like to let me
know and if you happen to be new to
anime uproar please don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
also don't forget to follow me on
twitter and instagram at anime uproar
for all the latest news and updates a
huge thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons for supporting our work I
want to give a special thank you to our
pro hero tier patrons including the one
and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson King's eldress keel on and
on he'll cruise another huge thank you
to our the one tier patrons the ones who
stand above all other clans including
baby Rey ace
Ingrid ah a Lola nada madam AK and
makoto-kun and at the very pinnacle of
interdimensional greatness the tier
reserved only for Legends a massive
thank you to Reagan Harrison a disciple
of Lords we go himself if you guys feel
that our content provides value for you
and you want to support more be sure to
check out our patreon link in the
description even donating a single
dollar will give you access to our anime
up for patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as always
thank you guys so much for watching I
really appreciate it and until next time
see us space cowboys
[Music]